- Nous n'avions jamais vu
si loin dans l'univers.
Les images et les spectres
captés par le téléscope spatial
James Webb offrent une nouvelle
perspective à l'humanité.
Chaque image offerte par Webb
est une découverte scientifique
en soi. La NASA en dévoile
aujourd'hui cinq.
L'image de fascinantes
nébuleuses, de gigantesques
nuages de gaz et de poussière.
L'analyse de l'exoplanète WASP-
96 b, composée essentiellement
de gaz, où l'on a trouvé la
présence d'eau, et puis le
groupement compact de galaxi de.
Une façon de montrer au monde
entier un aperçu des prouesses
dont est capable James Webb,
le plus puissant téléscope
jamais conçu.
RENÉ Dophysicien
- Moi-même qui est scientifique,
qui devrait être habitué
à ce genre de performance-là,
moi-même je suis surpris de voir
la qualité de ces images-là.
Ça fait 6 mois que ça dure
et enfin, on peut les partager
avec le public.
- Aux quatre coins du monde,
des astrendaient
ce moment. À Longueuil, à
l'Agence spatiale canadienne,
où des dizaines d'employés
s'étaient rassemblés, la
fébrilité était palpable.
- C'est quelque chose qu'on
attendait depuis très, très,
très longtemps.
- Car ces images pourront
changer notre compréhension
de l'univers.
ÉRIC DUPUIS, dir. développement
Agence spatiale canadienne
- Ce queous permettre
de faire, c'est de regarder
l'univers avec une profondeur
beaucoup plus grande qu'avant,
une précision beaucoup plus
grande qu'avant et d'aller
chercher des informations qu'on
n'avait pas encore.
- Il faut rappeler que
a a joué son rôle dans
la mise en oeuvre de la mission.
Il fournit deux instruments
essentiels : le guideurde préci,
le spectrographe et imageur du
téléscope.
NATHALIE OUELLETTE
astrophysicienne
- Tous les Canadiens doivent
ressentir une fierté, j'espère,
aujourd'hui.
- Et la mission de James Web
commence à peine.
- C'est vraiment un nouveau
chapitre dans l'histoire de
l'astronomie.
- Posté à 1,5 million de
kilomètres de la terre, le
téléscope devrait fonctionner
pour les 20 prochaines années et
répondre en partie aux questions
des humains.
Ici Kim Vermette, Radio-Canada,
Montréa